comencemos con este triángulo abc y
vemos en el dibujo que ya sabemos que la
longitud de ave es igual a la longitud
de ac o que el segmento de recta a b es
congruente con el segmento de recta hace
y dado que es un triángulo y dos lados
de este triángulo son congruentes o
tienen la misma longitud podemos decir
que este es un triángulo isósceles una
de las palabras son más difíciles de
deletrear creo que lo escribí bien y eso
simplemente significa que dos de los
lados son iguales ahora lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es demostrar lo que
quiero demostrar es que estos dos
ángulos que a veces se los conoce como
ángulos de base y son los que se forman
entre uno de los dos lados iguales y el
lado que no es necesariamente igual a él
y entre el otro lado que es igual y el
que no necesariamente es igual quiero
mostrar que son congruentes entonces
quiero probar que ese ángulo abc es
congruente con el ángulo acb en un
triángulo isósceles estos dos ángulos a
menudo se denominan ángulos de la base y
éste
arriba podría llamarse el ángulo del
vértice y estos lados del triángulo
isósceles a menudo se les llama patas y
el lado de aquí abajo que no
necesariamente tiene la misma longitud
que los otros dos se llama base entonces
veamos si podemos demostrar esto no
tenemos mucha información aquí solo que
estos dos lados son iguales pero ya
tenemos bastante información sobre
congruencia de triángulos entonces tal
vez podamos construir aquí dos
triángulos que sean congruentes y luego
podremos usar esa información para
determinar si este ángulo es congruente
con este otro ángulo y el primer paso si
vamos a utilizar la congruencia de
triángulos es construir dos triángulos
entonces una forma de construir dos
triángulos es establecer otro punto aquí
establezcamos el punto de y digamos que
d es el punto medio entre b y c es el
punto medio así que la distancia de
beade será la misma que la distancia de
de hace y obviamente entre dos puntos
tienes un punto medio permíteme dibujar
el segmento ade
y esto es útil porque ahora hemos
construido dos triángulos y lo que es
aún más genial es que el triángulo a vd
y el triángulo acd tienen este lado
congruente este otro lado congruente y
comparten este lado de aquí así que
sabemos que el triángulo abed es
congruente con el triángulo acd y lo
sabemos por el el lado lado lado si
tienes dos triángulos que tienen tres
lados que son congruentes o tienen la
misma longitud entonces los dos
triángulos son congruentes y esto es
útil porque si estos dos triángulos son
congruentes sus ángulos correspondientes
son congruentes con esto ya hemos
demostrado nuestro resultado porque el
ángulo correspondiente a abed en este
triángulo es el ángulo acd en este otro
triángulo entonces sabemos que el ángulo
abc es congruente con el ángulo acb este
es un resultado bastante bueno si tienes
un triángulo isósceles un triángulo
donde dos de los lados son congruentes
entonces sus ángulos de la base
estos ángulos de la base también serán
congruentes ahora pensemos en esto de
otra manera podríamos afirmar lo opuesto
si los ángulos de la base son
congruentes sabemos que estas dos patas
serán congruentes vamos a construir un
triángulo y veamos si podemos
demostrarlo al revés
así que dibujaré otro triángulo justo
aquí permíteme dibujarlo así aunque no
me está saliendo tan bonito entonces
llamaré a esto a llamaré a esto ve y
llamaré a esto sé justo allí y ahora
comenzaremos con la idea de que este
ángulo el ángulo abc es congruente con
el ángulo acb por lo que tendrían
exactamente la misma medida y lo que
queremos demostrar en este caso
permíteme dibujar una línea aquí para
mostrar que estamos probando una idea
diferente aquí estamos diciendo que si
estos dos lados son iguales entonces los
ángulos de la base serán iguales lo
hemos demostrado ahora queremos hacer lo
opuesto si los ángulos de la base son
iguales entonces los dos lados son
iguales por lo tanto queremos demostrar
que él
ace es congruente con ave o podríamos
decir que la longitud del segmento hace
que d notaremos de esta manera es igual
a la longitud del segmento ave estas son
declaraciones esencialmente equivalentes
entonces veamos entre las herramientas
que ya tenemos están los teoremas de
congruencia pero para aplicarlos
necesitamos tener dos triángulos así que
construyamos los triángulos aquí y esta
vez en lugar de definir otro punto como
el punto medio voy a definir de como el
punto que si viéramos abc como una recta
horizontal sería el punto que baja
directamente desde a y la razón por la
que digo esto es porque hay algún punto
que podríamos llamar altura que
intersecta bc en un ángulo recto
definitivamente existe un punto así
entonces si es un ángulo recto en este
lado si son 90 grados entonces sabemos
que también este otro ángulo mide 90
grados
ahora que tiene de interesante esto
permíteme escribir esto construir ade de
manera tal que
ade es perpendicular a veces y siempre
puedes construir una altura
esencialmente solo tienes que hacer que
veces sea una recta horizontal y luego
solo tienes que comenzar a dibujar una
recta desde a- y llegarás al punto de
siempre puedes hacerlo con un triángulo
como este entonces que nos da esto aquí
tenemos un ángulo un ángulo y luego un
lado en común y aquí tienes un ángulo
que corresponde a este ángulo un ángulo
que corresponde a este ángulo y el mismo
lado en común
sabemos que estos triángulos son
congruentes por el ángulo ángulo lado
que hemos mostrado que es un postulado
congruente válido entonces podemos decir
ahora que el triángulo abed es
congruente con el triángulo acb y lo
sabemos por ángulo ángulo lado este
ángulo y este ángulo y este lado este
ángulo y este ángulo y este lado y una
vez que sabemos que estos dos triángulos
son congruentes sabemos que cada ángulo
y lado correspondiente de los dos
triángulos también serán congruentes
entonces sabemos que a b
un lado correspondiente a hacer por lo
que estos dos deben ser congruentes así
que ave va a ser congruente con hace y
eso es porque éstos son triángulos
congruentes y hemos demostrado lo que
queríamos demostrar si los ángulos de la
base son iguales entonces las dos patas
serán iguales si las dos patas son
iguales entonces los ángulos de la base
son iguales es una herramienta muy muy
muy útil en geometría y en caso de que
tengas curiosidad para este triángulo
isósceles específico aquí configuramos
de como el punto medio acá configuramos
de para que esté directamente debajo de
a no dijimos si era el punto medio pero
aquí podemos mostrar que es el punto
medio como un pequeño resultado
adicional porque sabemos que dado que
estos dos triángulos son congruentes bd
será congruente con dc porque son los
lados correspondientes entonces en
realidad resulta que el punto de para un
triángulo isósceles no sólo es el punto
medio sino que es el punto en el que es
una bisectriz perpendicular de bc
entonces no sólo a d
perpendicular a veces sino que lo divide
a la mitad y de ese el punto medio de
toda esa base